welcome to this video playing my record
Lea corner all right if I lose on time
by some seconds it was the window okay
the Kings in yet I'm going to play him
what line maybe maybe some a6 business
and c5 this is what I haven't played
back then when I was regularly employing
the same issue
I can play a foyer I forgot
not a good move all I wanted to wanted
this this typical Benko wrinkle stop
lame okay but there's really no way back
now he's 6f form it's not really good so
yeah this is the worse worse version of
that Oh interesting
what is he trying to do playing for
kwikki chikki media with h4 don't really
believe in that with this counter play
on the beefer maybe but okay
hmm okay let's go with these six trying
to get a little bit more space here
takes Bishop takes should help me if he
goes FY just play 93 enter give up the
poem yeah here I thought that night c64
might be an additional option that
that's welcome
yeah if I go back in all this maybe f5m
okay let's let's play let's play
directly him if he goes 90 X I wonder
Queen b6 already intending c4 with check
and take b2 can also go five
yeah okay maybe you can do some
intermediate moves f5 or other than that
I just thought Knight takes T three and
go from there if I go c4 then
immediately Knight f2 should be okay if
I've probably Bishop c4 yeah we're
taking it looks weird on the other hand
I don't really know he can take you know
I don't I don't believe in that this is
simple
keeping the pawn for the moment asking
him how he wants to get it back Knight
takes Bishop takes Queen takes Group B -
yeah that's not a very natural situation
for the bishop but it still keeps this
pawn and b3 has weakened the white the
white pawn structure especially it has
put given up the protection for the 90m
whoa this is very sharp aged six maybe
probably should do that
so maybe he just plays aged for maybe he
does but night aged seven I don't see
how he protects the h4 pawn maybe also
just 97 for that Madea then maybe really
g5 as weird as it looks
James takes a 95 not sure about this
here I can play g5 everything else fails
I go g5 or just Queen e7 I guess there's
nothing wrong with Queen e7 maybe
possibly Queenie 525 now is this good
yeah then you just gonna a 4f B 3 at the
countin play you know I can just go here
a form yeah I can okay he will get it
back c4 maybe still then but 93 there is
some 93 there's no G form so yeah I can
I can insert this and see what he's
doing next
I have c4 also as a possible
continuation d2 d2 look III and c3 maybe
maybe
a for Bishop c6 takes rupee form maybe
just him trying to activate him
Brooke b3 takes rook b3 and a really
active position he's very much tied down
interesting let's look at d3 possibly
but this this is probably just okay here
this this loop in weights you can also
take C 3 and a 3 yeah maybe this is the
maybe this is the easiest don't want to
face g5 this looks very tricky okay he
cannot take here because of her gift to
still they cannot take cannot take
really white reserve yeah it was a
winning endgame though I don't really
know I mean I think you should just just
play it simpler and just right here just
just take it as what was the big problem
with this maybe I'm I'm not
understanding the position Queen b6 and
their thoughts well there's nothing
terrible happening even just rupee one
would be possible theoretically speaking
check this maybe then he's good at five
tricky tricky yeah maybe this is not bad
but I think he should take it back at
some point he he never got it back in
the game really
again he didn't take it and I think it
really should question is what now on IG
for I can also go here could be
interesting and this is this
counter-attack yeah he's very loose am
probably will lose one or two pounds
tough position gather round here widest
somewhat somewhat falling apart I think
yeah here it's not not tenable anymore
okay thanks for watching